***
Er verändert ständig seine Identität.
*spannende Musik*
Er stiehlt etwas aus dem Louvre.
Durch clevere Ablenkungsmanöver
entkommt er der Polizei.
Assane Diop alias "Lupin"
ist ein echter Meisterdieb.
Wie er das macht
und warum das in echt funktioniert,
klären wir jetzt.
*spannende Musik*
Tag zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Ob man Fan von Omar Sy ist
oder nicht,
in der Netflix-Serie "Lupin"
ist für alle was dabei.
Action, Familiendrama
und ein bisschen Love Story.
Aber das zentrale Thema
ist Assane Diop als Meisterdieb.
Er zieht sehr lässig
ganz schön krasse Dinger ab.
Wir haben uns seine Methoden
etwas genauer angeschaut.
Hier kommt Nummer 1.
*spannende Musik*
Assane Diop nimmt in der Serie
mehrfach eine andere Identität an.
Er wird unter falschem Namen
als Reinigungskraft
beim Louvre angestellt.
Er gibt sich als Millionär
und als IT-Mitarbeiter aus.
Und wir sehen ihn
als alten Mann im Fernsehen.
Immer erreicht er
in der Verkleidung sein Ziel.
Arsène Lupin,
der Gentleman-Gauner.
Assane Diop
nutzt ein einfaches Prinzip.
Unsere Wahrnehmung von anderen
basiert v.a. auf Stereotypen.
Dieses Buch von 2 Sozialpsychologen
beschäftigt sich umfangreich damit.
Die Hauptaussage:
Unsere Welt ist sehr komplex.
Genauso wie
das nahe soziales Umfeld.
Um schnell Entscheidungen zu treffen,
greift das Gehirn
auf bekannte Muster zurück.
So ordnet es Informationen ein.
Das kennen wir
vom "Schubladendenken".
Wir nehmen etwas wahr,
z.B. die Kleidung eines Menschen.
Und packen ihn in eine Schublade.
Z.B. Anzug = reich,
Brille = intelligent.
Fahrrad
= ökologisches Bewusstsein.
Wenn wir das nicht reflektieren,
führt das zu einer großen Schwäche.
Wir nehmen nur das wahr,
was wir wahrnehmen wollen,
was in unser Bild passt.
Und blenden Ungereimtheiten aus.
Das macht sich Lupin zunutze.
Niemand achtet
auf den Reinigungsmann.
Für die meisten ist er unsichtbar.
Auf dem roten Teppich,
mit schickem Anzug
und teurer Uhr,
wird der gleiche Mensch
glaubhaft zum Millionär.
Vor allem, wenn der Internetauftritt
auch noch gut ist.
Solche Strategien werden auch
bei echten Verbrechen genutzt.
Erinnert ihr euch an den Goldraub
um den Deutsch-Rapper Xatar?
*Hiphop-Musik*
Sie verkleideten sich
als Polizisten der Steuerfahndung,
So haben sie
die Fahrer eines Goldtransports
von der Autobahn runterbekommen
und in ihre Falle gelockt.
Bei dem Raub erbeutete die Gang
lt. offiziellen Angaben
120 kg Schmuck und Zahngold
im Wert von 1,7 Mio. Euro.
Lange hielt die Täuschung nicht an.
Die Fingerabdrücke
führten die Polizei
schnell auf die Spur von Xatar.
Er wurde 3 Monate später
im Irak festgenommen.
Poah, das war sick, Digga.
Deutlich länger konnte Gerd Postel
sein Umfeld täuschen.
Nämlich 17 Jahre lang.
Obwohl er nur als Postbote
ausgebildet war,
arbeitete er zwischen 1980 und 1997
mit gefälschten Urkunden als Arzt.
Und als Psychiater.
Z.T. in leitenden Positionen.
Mir unterstanden 40 Assistenzärzte,
8 Psychologen und mehrere Oberärzte.
Zur Vorbereitung besuchte er viele
Psychologie- und Soziologiekurse
an der Uni Bremen.
Er las Fachliteratur
und versuchte,
die medizinische Fachsprache
so gut wie möglich zu imitieren.
Das hat offenbar gereicht,
um Menschen mehrfach zu täuschen.
Vielleicht sogar sich selbst.
Ich wusste nicht weniger
über Psychiatrie als diese Leute.
Vermutlich mehr.
Seine Machenschaften
flogen immer wieder auf.
Er wurde mehrfach verurteilt,
aber immer zu geringen Strafen.
Das hielt ihn nicht davon an,
einfach weiterzumachen.
Das Landgericht Leipzig
verurteilte ihn 1999 dann
u.a. wegen Betrugs, Urkundenfälschung
und dem Missbrauch akademischer Titel
zu einer Freiheitsstrafe
von 4 Jahren.
Xatar und Gerd Postel
sind nichts im Vergleich zu ihm:
Frank Abagnale
ist der König der Täuschungen.
Im Alter von 15 bis 21 Jahren
soll er mehr als 8 Identitäten
angenommen haben.
U.a. die eines Gefängnisbeamten,
eines Anwalts,
eines Arztes
und sogar eines Piloten.
Mit diesen Identitäten
hat er u.a. Scheckbetrug betrieben
und damit einen Schaden
von 2,5 Mio. US-Dollar verursacht.
Er hat sich so raffiniert angestellt,
dass er nach seiner Festnahme
sogar einen Job vom FBI
angeboten bekommen hat.
Und zwar als Sicherheitsberater,
um mit seiner Erfahrung
andere Kriminelle aufzuspüren.
Weil das so unglaublich ist,
landete die Geschichte
auch in Hollywood.
Sie wurde verfilmt
in "Catch me if you can".
Can I see some identification?
You can never be too careful
these days.
Wir halten fest:
Die Täuschungen
von Assane Diop in "Lupin"
finden wir so ähnlich
auch in der realen Welt wieder.
Aber er hat noch mehr drauf.
Hier kommt Strategie Nummer 2.
*spannende Musik*
In der 1. Staffel
schmiedet Assane Diop den Plan,
ein Collier aus dem Louvre
zu stehlen.
Er lässt sich unter falschem Namen
als Reinigungskraft anstellen,
lässt ein Duplikat
des Colliers erstellen
und heuert Kriminelle an.
Ohne dass sie es wissen,
sollen sie nur für Ablenkung sorgen.
Er ersteigert das Collier selbst.
Er tauscht es aus und sorgt dafür,
dass er als Reinigungskraft
damit am nächsten Tag unbehelligt
aus dem Louvre laufen kann.
Ich blieb an der Szene hängen,
die den Austausch des Colliers zeigt.
Lupin greift sich das Original
und schmeißt es in den Mülleimer,
während er fällt.
Als er auf dem Boden aufkommt,
schiebt er die Fälschung
elegant über den Boden.
Klar könnte man denken:
Das ist doch obvious.
Er hatte das Collier
gerade noch in der anderen Hand.
Aber das ist wie bei Zaubertricks.
Wissen wir,
wie sie funktionieren,
ist alles offensichtlich.
Aber wenn wir das nicht wissen,
fallen wir darauf herein.
Diese Tricks lenken ganz gezielt
unseren Fokus.
Schaut euch das an:
Der Magier klaut dem Typen die Uhr
direkt vor seiner Nase,
obwohl er es vorher angekündigt hat.
Er lenkt den Fokus auf etwas anderes
und nutzt dabei aus,
dass unser Gehirn sich
nicht auf mehrere Dinge gleichzeitig
konzentrieren kann.
Wenn ihr es ausprobieren wollt,
dann zählt in diesem Video,
wie oft der Ball
hin- und hergeworfen wird.
Aber nur von den Personen in Weiß.
*ruhige Musik*
Ist euch was aufgefallen?
Der Gorilla mitten im Bild?
Wenn ja,
gehört ihr zur Minderheit.
Oder kanntet das schon.
Dieses psychologische Experiment
aus den 90ern
wurde oft durchgeführt
und kam immer zum gleichen Ergebnis.
Wenn sich unser Gehirn
stark auf eine Sache fokussiert,
blenden wir anderes aus.
Vereinfacht gesagt:
Ablenkung ist das Wichtigste.
Genau das sehen wir bei "Lupin".
*dramatische Musik*
Das Prinzip der Ablenkung
nutzen auch echte Kriminelle.
Z.B. bei einem spektakulären Bankraub
1995 in Berlin.
(Archiv) "Tunnelgangster
heißen die Hauptfiguren
im spektakulärsten Bankraub Berlins."
4 Männer stürmten eine Bankfiliale,
nahmen Geiseln,
verdunkelten Fenster und schalteten
Überwachungskameras aus.
Und legten Handgranaten
vor die Türen.
Ihre Forderung: 17 Mio. Mark Lösegeld
und ein Fluchtfahrzeug.
So weit, so klassisch.
Die Polizei sperrte das Viertel ab,
bildete ein Sondereinsatzkommando
und versuchte, zu verhandeln
und das Lösegeld zu beschaffen.
Aber das dauerte eben.
Diese Zeit
haben die Bankräuber genutzt.
Die Polizei dachte, dass sie
mit dem geforderten Fahrzeug fliehen.
Sie verließen jedoch die Bank
über einen vorher angelegten
unterirdischen Gang.
*spannende Musik*
Ein cleveres Ablenkungsmanöver.
6 von den vermutlich 11 Tätern
wurden rasch gefasst und verurteilt.
Von den anderen und 50% der Beute
fehlt aber bis heute jede Spur.
Es war keine Blamage
im eigentlichen Sinne.
Denn damit konnte man nicht rechnen.
Ablenkung ist eine gute Strategie,
die auch im echten Leben klappt.
Diese Räuber waren eine ganze Gruppe.
Und sie haben auch "nur"
eine Bank überfallen.
Assane Diop hingegen arbeitet allein.
Und er klaut im Louvre.
*spannende Musik*
Der Louvre
ist eines der berühmtesten Museen.
Da drin hängen krasse Kunstwerke.
Da einzubrechen
ist völlig unmöglich.
Oder?
Auf die heutige Sicherheitstechnik
mag das zutreffen.
Aber der Louvre ist der Tatort
von einem der krassesten
Kunstdiebstähle der Geschichte.
Bei dem wurde
das berühmteste Gemälde geklaut:
die "Mona Lisa".
Beginnen wir von vorne.
1911 war der Italiener
Vincenzo Peruggia überzeugt,
dass die "Mona Lisa"
als Gemälde von Leonardo da Vinci
nach Italien gehört.
Und nicht in den Louvre.
You know what?
Fuck these assholes.
Er hat sich
als Glaser anstellen lassen,
um das Museum
auskundschaften zu können.
Da sieht man gute Parallelen
zu "Lupin".
Als Tag für den Diebstahl
wählte er einen Montag.
Der Louvre war montags
für Besucher geschlossen.
Und es war wenig Personal dort.
Aber einige Leute mussten arbeiten.
Mit ihnen hat sich Peruggia
durch den Angestellten-Eingang
ins Museum geschlichen.
Das Schutzglas für die "Mona Lisa"
hat er selbst hergestellt.
Er konnte es also schnell entfernen.
Er entfernte den Holzrahmen
und versteckte die "Mona Lisa"
unter einem großen Kittel.
Dass das Bild weg war,
fiel erst nach über 24 Stunden auf.
Peruggia hatte also
genug Zeit zu fliehen.
Aber er ist nicht weit abgehauen.
Er hat die "Mona Lisa" 2 Jahre lang
in seiner Wohnung in Paris versteckt.
Geschnappt wurde er beim Versuch,
das Gemälde an einen
Antiquitätenhändler zu verkaufen.
Er hatte trotzdem
ein bisschen Erfolg.
Vor der Rückgabe des Gemäldes
an den Louvre
wurde es noch in Mailand,
Florenz und Rom ausgestellt.
Peruggia wurde deshalb in Italien
als Nationalheld gefeiert.
Geschichten über Meisterdiebe
sind schon faszinierend.
Und "Lupin" kommt uns noch
so unglaublich sympathisch vor.
Deswegen meine Frage:
Habt ihr eine geheime Faszination
für die Tricks und Kniffe
dieser Diebe?
Oder sind das für euch Verbrecher,
die einfach in den Knast gehören?
Und was habt ihr schon mal geklaut?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Abonniert bitte diesen Kanal
und drückt die Glocke.
Dann sehen wir uns bald wieder.
Ich freue mich drauf,
ciao, ciao.
Wenn ihr Lust
auf noch mehr Heist-Serien habt,
schaut hier oben
bei "Haus des Geldes".
Wenn ihr aber
lieber True Crime wollt,
gibt es echte Verbrechen
auf dem Kanal "Der Fall".
Copyright MDR 2023